okay let's do it let's see some oldies
boring work with Nixon it no his old
videos are good and then before he let's
see he took the pill welcome back guys
today we have a very juicy video on Deck
because me and ELO always agree we
always go into a video agreeing and
being like this this is cancer let's
talk about it yeah but this time I hope
you're ready to go to war when I saw
this video I was like yo Ela look how
stupid this is we need to talk about it
and she looks at me and she goes well
that bad maybe we shouldn't talk about
and I was like oh [ __ ] dude we need to
have some beef on camera right now so
we've been putting doing this video off
for a minute because Ila was like this
is a real issue it is an issue you but
the video is ridiculous what do you
think it's going to be about mom what
are some real issues in fact 2016 issues
I can't even remember there's been so
many
Finn who can even remember that far the
issue is by the way man spreading oh
demand spreading if you don't know is
when a man is on a bus or Subway or any
public place and apparently according to
these women on a buzzfeed yes it's
BuzzFeed all men sit like this by the
way what's the deal with how women take
up every [ __ ] seat with their bags
I've seen more women taking up [ __ ]
empty subway seats with their [ __ ]
purses then I've seen men spreading
their legs I have never seen them yeah
you know exactly what I'm talking about
yeah I told you I'm going to war let's
go to war together let's Jump Right In
to this BuzzFeed exclusive 10 exciting
ways to pit to make men look like little
[ __ ] my balls what would you say is a
bigger problem men man spreading or
women putting their bags on on seats
guaranteed bags guarantees oh you'd
agree okay I've been on the sub I was
riding the subway whatever for the buses
from when I was 13. buses and Subway
really from whatever was 13 and then
when I was like 15 to 16 I was on the
Subways seven days a week in New York
City okay man spreading was never a
thing meant if I walked on the subway
and there was a seat next to them they
they set them straight so I could sit
next to them but a woman you gotta walk
over and be like excuse me because she
couldn't sit there because your [ __ ]
purse is on there
look at this guy is he doing is he doing
anything wrong sitting like that he's
sitting comfortably where in a place
where he has plenty of so much space
well [ __ ] off it's not about balls
sticking delay it's about literally
smashing my balls and testicles like I
see dainty little girls sitting on the
subway okay and that like this they sit
like this and God bless them good for
them I have [ __ ] here I can't it
switched my junk I gotta sit like this I
agree with that okay
like by the way and look at the clip
they're showing that guy's sitting like
pretty [ __ ] reasonably his legs are
closer than her oh but a good thing I'm
like four seconds in and I'm already
pissed off I'm already straight
triggered BuzzFeed kidnap children sex
trafficking let's let's make it right
there with some movement about it I mean
man because I can't stand BuzzFeed well
I see your point because you're like I
we can have a normal conversation about
this without making it sound like men
need to be beheaded and their heads put
on stage exactly they make it so extreme
that being said you're wrong it's it's
like when social justice Warriors
wrong feminism right it's I I care about
feminism but then there's this extreme
one right the completely run it for
everyone are you female splending me
right now yeah I feel like do you know
when a female explains something that's
very condescending no you're right
you're like a totally different person
back then compared to now just like yeah
he's like a sex trafficker like I'm just
depressed and fat I know let's be
careful judging him though because it's
like because what's going to happen if
we're in six years we're gonna be
different right okay we'll be better or
not all I ask is like are they
vaccinated like
what like bro it's just it's just cringy
completely agree with you man spreading
is when a man spreads his physical body
to take up as much space as humanly
possible take up as much space as
humanly possible the clips show men
seating in my opinion reasonably yeah I
agree I agree which is why it's so I
know much space is humanly possible
implying that I'm sitting on the subway
like this is all me she's talking about
it like big
to do it on purpose yeah yeah let's see
how much space I can take let's see how
many women I can piss off today on the
subway ride that's what I'm thinking
about the people around you are
relegated to a very small portion that
one's pretty bad that one's pretty bad
that happens though yes it has been fine
but go back to that go back to that
image right there of this pretty bad
okay just plenty of space she's a tiny
little thing okay even though he is
crossing the line there barely all she
has to say is is me and he'll go oh
sorry and he'll and he'll put his leg in
that's it maybe he's just
absent-mindedly sitting like a normal
[ __ ] human being does sometimes that
one's pretty bad that happens though
okay
this guy's a douchebag because it's an
episode about man spreading and one of
them has been kind of uh Lisa has blue
hair I agree I think most men on the
inside she does pretty good about this
and they're so quiet speak up this is
ridiculous thank you thanks for saying
that but the key to man spreading is not
noticing we grow up on two different
tracks people who man's register
socialize not to worry about it okay
what are those romance spreading they
weren't even taking up more than their
seat stop it stop finding [ __ ]
reasons to complain and if anyone out
here is doing it in a in a non-woke way
pay attention to yourself and make sure
just no complaining look at this no
complaining Earth is a [ __ ] mean
horrible Place get used to it hope for
the best it's the same one that was just
saying how 99 of men are angels these
guys are sitting like this because
they're being really respectful look at
this guy on the right he's sitting away
from the person next to him so he
doesn't intrude on their space this is a
nice guy and you're showing him like oh
[ __ ] this they literally haven't showed
one unreasonable clip yet in my opinion
they just complain and complain and
complain BuzzFeed oh they're [ __ ]
worse and you're showing him like oh
[ __ ] this [ __ ] you damn
she's just what woman explaining me yeah
I know what Tan's doing and it's
BuzzFeed you need to blame BuzzFeed not
her no I blame tan it's like yeah when
the Nazis okay said I was just following
orders what is tan should I move the
face again same exact [ __ ] there's so
many Vivid
men telling me to close my legs close
your legs maybe that was about something
lady you should close your legs I have
so many Vivid memories of my mom telling
me to close my legs tan listen this is
about man spreading I don't know what
traumatic [ __ ] you've been through but
leave that out of it so when I always
have your legs open in my high school
when we took photographs we weren't
allowed to cross our legs at the knee we
had to sit upright and cross our legs at
the ankle for the photographs because
that was apparently more ladylike have
any of you guys watched old Ethan
because this is like he used to be funny
this didn't create trauma yeah I like
this old Ethan video yeah you should
watch old Ethan and maybe if we all
watch old Ethan he'll he'll come back to
life again and he'll remember who he
really is because he's just a
middle-aged miserab now it's such a
shame why do you always have your legs
open tan close your legs as a child of
my mom telling me to close my legs
disgusting tan close your legs the whole
family close your legs
damn would you close your legs for
crisis
I kind of secretly hope to annoy some
men
that's my first train trip as a man
spreader I just feel like a monster
already how can you do this every day
without being conscious of it okay okay
you are being an obnoxious person that
is not man spreading that is just like
that's just being an obnoxious person it
just man spread on the bus for maybe a
final answer can you at least
acknowledge a lady and you're sitting
like a seven-year-old boy you're sitting
like a dirt bag by Lady standards so
maybe somebody is gonna look at you
especially an older woman who's gonna
say sweetheart sit up and close your
legs that men's have [ __ ] wigs and
berries between their legs like if I cut
off my dick and balls which is
apparently what you want me to do I
could happily sit with my thighs closed
stay two of man spreading and I forgot
that I had to do this how about purse
spreading let's make a Buzzfeed video
about first spreading no woman spreading
with their the few pictures that he
showed of like women's purses being on
seats have all been bigger problems than
any of the man spreading clips that
they've shown there hasn't been one bad
man spreading clip I have been that
broad on the on any public
transportation
spread out and then someone comes on and
I'm like oh sorry because I have manners
and I'll pull it all together I don't
know what's with women why they think
they have to bring the whole kitchen and
the kitchen sink with them in their
purse okay not my problem put it in your
[ __ ] lap next time woman spread
I don't know about that dude that's real
you all know that one whenever a woman
takes up space she's considered bossy
she's considered aggressive there are a
lot of stereotypes surrounding black
women and whether or not we're angry or
dominant and so maybe a lot of the
reasons why I do minimalize my presence
is because I don't want to be perceived
or engage with those stereotypes or you
gotta acknowledge that if you're wearing
a dress I understand that like why she
said is wearing stereotypes and all that
but you're wearing a dress that's such a
good point when you're opening up your
your crotch Crush I mean yeah it's weird
yeah it's weird and like not because
you're a woman because you're wearing
this girl with her legs spread in a
dress has no class it's that simple no
class no class at all no class and then
you can't understand why you're treated
as second class Nico's girlfriend broke
up with him over the Aiden e date
there's no way
by one of your own
[Music]
legs that's so important
what no it's really stupid oh God what
is it between their legs that's so
important that it requires two to three
seats when there are kids families women
and elderly people standing up okay no
one does that but it requires two to
three seats literally [ __ ] Hulk Hogan
that's a good layout she's saying that
requires
tip storage and not take two to three
maybe he'll take three seats
women are expected to be quiet small and
almost invisible whereas dude this guy
is doing his absolute best in what world
are women expected to be quiet small and
invisible where in America or England or
any Civilized Nation I apparently am not
speaking loud enough no I'm whispering
nobody's complaining you you tell
stories where you're in my ear
Whispering men can be this boisterous
slobs and it's all good today how can
you show this in good conscious and be
like all men are [ __ ] monsters here's
a drunk homeless guy taking a nap on the
bus he's not even man spreading he's
just [ __ ] passed out
something is wrong there yeah there's
not it's not demand spreading yeah the
guy clearly yeah maybe this is our uh
should I call 9-1-1 kind of a video or
pull the emergency cord on the subway
instead of taking this app passed out
person as an opportunity to be that's so
sure that's crazy so your social justice
[ __ ] oh man's man because let's just
roast homeless people on the internet I
can I can say man spreading came and
went as a flash in the pan and it's not
even gonna make a history because it was
that stupid so the fact that we're even
talking about it six years later is is
our own stupidity quite frankly
problems go deeper than man spreading at
this point
I've not enjoyed this week at all the
very first day where a group of people
came on they were going to a game and
they were all desperate for a seat and I
was taking up three seats that's not mad
spreading that's just you being a
[ __ ] [ __ ] this is so stupid I was
at manspring your legs are closed you're
just being a [ __ ] dick you're not
even following the old your only rules
of your experiment I can't even imagine
sitting there not giving a seat so I
don't know about you but I was raised I
know about you but I was raised if an
elderly person comes on you immediately
pop up give them your seat if a pregnant
lady comes on pop up give them your seat
someone with crutches yeah any any
crutches right anything my my privileges
as a white male is to stand up it's
[ __ ] wonderful and getting a little
older like some 20 year old with good
manners would be like oh have a seat and
I'm like based mom is that you I'm like
babe take a seat basement take a seat
your only rules of your experiment by
the way I have seen women believe it or
not sitting like that on the bus or
Subway me too it happens to both genders
to be forced to man spread really showed
me how up your own ass you have to be as
a person to not be conscious of those
around you so today I'm doing a man
spreading experiment I want to behave
like all men do and just this is how all
men sit on the subway
yo
yo yo yo what the [ __ ] yo get out of
here be forced to man spread really
showed me how up your own ass you have
to be as a person
yeah Tana's going to win employee of the
of the year
10.
all right so just just so you know shut
his mouth grandma just decided to vacuum
and the dog's barking at the vacuum
sorry about the background guys but
nobody I guess that thing was showing
this doesn't mean two weeks we're going
to be at our new home in Florida and
it's going to be all pieces in the back
let me go grab the dog
she's gonna be like you triggered males
so hard with that video that we are
giving you this statue of a penis and
balls because that you've apparently
never seen one before and we just want
to let you know what they look like you
did such a great job missing the point
exactly what we were looking for you
promoted I'm jealous because sometimes I
see you in really tight fitting pants
and you're sitting there and you're
really cute little like put together and
you don't take up a lot of space like
they're complaining about and I'm like
dude I'm actually jealous but I want to
I wouldn't want to very sensitive stuff
too like you get punched in the balls
the wrong way you will puke the pain is
so severe like I'm just saying you you
guys have gone about this in such a in
such a bad way that frankly all the
respect I had for BuzzFeed is now gone I
went from zero to zero okay the man
that's taking up too much space on a bus
on the plane on the bench we see you you
don't need that much room to the young
women out there say you should
definitely be aware of your surroundings
if there's something that you want if
there's something you want to say if
there's a position that you want to hold
take up that space you deserve that
space what a what a message of
empowerment how does that make you feel
dude let me feel like next time on on a
train I should lay yeah over three seats
you kind of taking up a little space
here well she said I need to be more
confident take up that space so many
Vivid memories as a child of my mom
telling me to close my legs while the
BuzzFeed says it's true then I better
[ __ ] just here you go dude make
yourself at home this is how everyone
needs to sit on the subway from now on
so men make sure to offer your shoulders
and leg space so all women as reparation
for the man spreading that is taken on
by her he was so he was great yeah all
the old Ethan used to be cool but Ethan
can be cool again let's let's give Ethan
a shot maybe if we all just say a prayer
for Ethan he'll come back to life
hopefully what do you give what do you
give old eat then one to ten it was one
of the first podcasts I ever watched
when you were watching it I remember
coming in here and being like what's
this and yeah and you said this is H3
and I said oh okay and I sat and watched
with you a little bit and I thought this
is cool I liked it so back then I would
have given it you know probably an eight
out of ten and then recently I don't
even want to judge what was recently
because I felt it was kind of sad indeed
but now I I believe in Ethan and I
believe he can snap out of it he needs
to figure things out though he's got to
figure his [ __ ] out oh God no cat
[Music]